so keeping with the theme of the
sundowner which I love this terminology
how often have you seen other actors
that you deem more talented than
yourself turn around and quit go
somewhere new and what does that do to
you inside well I've seen it happen I
don't know the exact number of people
that have decided to move on and not
stay in the business but when somebody
leaves and I sometimes you don't know
they're gone until you just don't see
him for a while and you reminded and
that they're not here what it makes me
feel is you know better than than me
this is what I signed up for this is
what I want to do this is what I've
wanted to do since I was a little boy I
loved to tell stories I love to have the
opportunity to perhaps get somebody to
see something in a way that they didn't
think about looking at something before
or feel something that previously they
have not felt or look at something in a
way that they just haven't hadn't
occurred to them to look at something
and and maybe it'll help change the
world in some tiny tiny tiny way and I
think that's a great calling I do and
that's one that's why I'm here so for
those that for those that leave god
bless them and they had their reasons
and I don't know what those reasons were
but they don't concern me and I just
step up and take their place in line and
try to make try to make them proud if we
were friends and try to make everybody
else proud that I'm work with that I'm
working with that we've had this
opportunity together and
maybe we can do something special with
the opportunity
you